DeSantis demolished nome's arguments so
devastatingly that nuum had to return
for his closing argument to Absolute
piffle meaningless platitudes we all
want to be loved we need to be loved we
all want to be protected respected and
connected I think there is a Unity frame
here okay uh you said it well I mean I I
Ron I have no doubt Ronda sis loves this
country I love this country it's not
about red versus blue it's red white and
blue the United States of America and I
think we're better off and we're all
better off and so I appreciate this
conversation I appreciate you Ron being
a family man you got three incredible
kids I appreciate your wife your
sacrifice and I appreciate your military
service but I also appreciate we do have
fundamental differences about the fate
and future of this country and that's
why I'm going to be working so hard to
get Joe Biden and kamla Harris reelected
in 2024 whoa total colle he that guy had
nothing that was like the love child of
Patrick baitman and kamla Harris